car il est l'heure à présent de notre
rubrique du vendredi soir nous passons
un jour avec joseph payet je vous en
parlais cet éleveur laitier dont le
troupeau était décimée par la low cost
bovine il a porté plainte contre la
sicalait et contre le cabinet métairie
maire chargé du suivi de ces bêtes un
drame humain c'est ce que vit cet
éleveur ainsi que des dizaines d'autres
une détresse et qu'il a confié à
jean-marc collienne et laurent fignon
nous sommes dans le champ de joseph
payet au petit tampon à la fin des
années 90 joseph payet avait une
quarantaine de vaches laitières
aujourd'hui il a tout perdu c'est l'art
un créole et la véronique en bas du
laurier des soignants chou citrouille
depuis quelques mois genève payet s'est
remise au maraîchage comme il ya trente
ans quand il a commencé à travailler la
terre
en 1997 il s'était lancé dans l'élevage
laitier touché comme trois-quarts des
élevages de lille par la leucose bovine
son troupeau était décimée lourdement
endetté joseph payet a dû revendre ses
terres aujourd'hui il est obligé de
louer cette petite parcelle pour
cultiver ses oignons
aujourd'hui que maraîchage ou vivent
bien ben là noms me viennent commencé
moi d'autres là et il fait que la mère
assa y met
comme on dit ça à mon courage à deux
mains en disant pas fait quelque chose
si tu y es tu toutes les embrouilles que
j'avais dans ma tête
essayez de pour pas aller devant le
moral comment maintenant dire que est ce
que le moral les biens non c'est qu'ils
sont accolés gravée au nom de tête des
graves et voies avoir cru à une
profession et que la ramène à eau à une
destruction morale financière et tout
lui tout bon sens donc aujourd'hui vous
bazire que tout oubli tout ce que vous
avez vous l'a vécue dans l'est dans les
15 à 15 heures qui viennent passer la
père de quatre enfants grand-père à
présent joseph payet repense aujourd'hui
à toutes ces années où il a trimé debout
à 4 heures du matin pour traire ses
vaches tous les jours de l'année
moi mes enfants m'a pas reconnue moi je
suis passé 18 ans à 12 heures par jour
dans les tables automatiquement s'il
n'est pas dans les tables c'était dans
le dans le champ
on regrette oui joseph payet regrette
surtout que ses deux fils ne puisse pas
travailler avec lui mais les quelques
légumes qu'ils cultivent à présent ne
lui permettent même pas de vivre
adieu les vaches production
l'exploitation de joseph payet n'est
plus aujourd'hui qu'un souvenir
voilà justement donc l'étape de 42
vaches plus le quai dans l'étape
le langage est là et il ya les prairies
l'été le côté joseph payet nous emmène
vers les installations laissées à
l'abandon et tables qui est de 13
bureaux et hangars à l'époque l'éleveur
avait investi plus de 300000 euros
labat tous les vaches les il rentrait de
trois fois par jour le matin plâtre est
et le sort pour le plateau 6 et le midi
points pour l'aliment et le quai de
traite ces deux là bas et dans ce temps
là me faisais 710 deux jours au début
après v à fin 2002 début 2003 c'est la
catastrophe qui est arrivée et après le
rendement a baissé qui que la manama et
pas mal de voir ici qui a crevé dirai
sans plus vraiment une étape avant non
la fibroïne devenu alors là il devenu un
stock n'est pas de départ donc tout ça
c'est stop deux cadavres non mais le
rôle le vrai but de l'étape c'était pas
ça un moment où tu es vivent bien toute
activité c'était le début me disais pas
vivait bien mais au moins c'était que le
terreau croissance c'était que 7 708
joue à me couvrir à peu près
à peu près un peu tout les charges mais
après au dessous de sa saisine on ne
peut pas des visiteurs arrivent
daniel beck vient prendre des nouvelles
de joseph payet saint louis bien ben j
essaye daniel bègue et le président de
l'as des phares l'association de défense
des agriculteurs de la réunion bien de
cette défaut nude il est bien parce que
je vais pas popote beau d'aimables voilà
positive autour d'un café joseph payet
évoque sa vie depuis qu'il a arrêté
l'élevage laitier en 2013 la vie d'un
père de famille obligées de vivre aux
crochets de sa femme et de ses enfants
madame elle y travaille et elle y gagne
et se sont petit peu mais après ma vie
ma fille aussi des fois quand arrive une
secouse yeux eh ben c'est elle qui
viendront se voit donc théoriquement
c'était le contraire ne mendie pense pas
un pet famille arrivée à la lma pour moi
est ce que c'est un déshonneur ou est-ce
que ça ne veut pas mieux me grey par
mail par des gens en ont blessé des
situations qui ne viennent pas possible
comment près aussi ont eu les jeunes
reprennent des exploitations quand ils
voient que l'apparent non pas six
même si de niro on va dire besoin
d'aller tout d'une famille voit la
nourriture passent des fois même au
niveau de l'alimentation les famines les
plus rien à manger des drames dans cette
infamie des séparations se croiser des
divorces des gens qui tentent dans la
colle mais même familialement ça a été
dur être très très très très dur
ces régionales il ya des moments bon ne
peut pas tout raconter mais c'est comme
titre et dieu sait que me résume ce que
ne peut pas dire tout vite tous les
événements que la claque la rive que la
rive à moi ou à plusieurs dans ce
domaine théoriquement le nie pas désiré
un mot mais c'était c'était le pont
d'entre d'eux carrément sadc plus
c'était pas là pour défendre un métier
pour expliquer votre problème et c'est à
dire c'était de prendre le relais direct
à l'est par les plus vieux en finir il
ya des moments oui mais après mon médium
avait au moins dit fatigué mais joseph
payet ne veut pas s'appesantir sur ce
passé douloureux
alors il nous emmène chez un jeune
éleveur à quelques kilomètres
bonjour pour faire partager avec
monsieur payet là on fait un jour avec
lui comme ça il explique un peu sa
situation
ceux qui continuent autour comment dans
quelle situation ils sont mais le jeune
éleveur ne veut pas être filmés comme la
plupart de ceux qui difficilement
continuer à produire du lait il a peur
de parler
il a aujourd'hui 35 baisse il en a perdu
une il y a quelques jours mais il ne
sait pas si c'était à cause de la
leucose bovine lui les plus la norme ans
que koshita de toute façon il a
l'intention d'arrêter l'exploitation
dans un an ou deux parce que dit il le
métier trop dur la chaussée lac blanc et
noirs dans le milieu d'accord c'est
surtout que c'est ça les plus fragiles
savent ou pensent quand aujourd'hui
donnée dire il faut plus boire le lait
de la réunion il faut plus manger la
viande de la réunion c'est pas moins de
10 ans assez de ces îles à des études
fait donc il faut croire les études mais
pas moins que à l'époque n'était que
l'éleveur mémoire
scientifique aujourd'hui il ya de moins
en moins l'élevage moins en moins de
vaches laitières et horaires prévus à
bordeaux qui aura plus d'éleveurs bay a
dit il aura plus de problèmes mais ça
n'est pas parce que quoi parce qu'il a
plu problèmes n'y a plus de deux heures
il s' y restent une cinquantaine sur 150
il assure une cinquantaine actif joseph
payet lui à tourner la page mais ça ne
l'empêchent pas de donner encore un coup
de main à huy débouté une première fois
après avoir porté plainte contre la
sicalait qui lui avait vendu des vaches
malades et contre le cabinet vétérinaire
chargé du suivi de ces bêtes
il attend le jugement en appel au mois
de mars ils estiment le préjudice subi à
un million d'euros le préjudice moral
lui est inestimable